das gefäß ja fast alles drin los
das rote sind die mieten leider verloren
grüne sind die gewinner lohse es sind
fragen die roten sind total
unverständnis fragen würde man nie
fragen die grünen wir sind so haben sie
fragen würde mir auch nie fragen aber du
kannst selber entscheiden das gibt s
doch alles gar nicht kommt ja immer nur
auf die antworten und ich
nehme gleich eine handvoll
so ich habe jetzt mal eine grüne sich
bei eigentlich war das sind immer so die
momente wo ich mich als zuschauer extrem
langweile wenn es schnell geht und
was macht sie so beliebt ja das stelle
ich mal in frage
ich bin ich nicht beliebt
also ich bin im privatleben
glaube ich schon beliebt
ja was heißt beliebt man mag mich sie so
wie ich auch meine freunde mag
im beruflichen nicht als beliebt es
kommt darauf an wann bei denen wieder
jahren bei anderen nein also wenn ich
irgendwo hingeht so wie heute ich fühle
mich gut und es ist eine schöne
atmosphäre hier dann
werden wir uns alle wahrscheinlich nicht
in erinnerung bleiben aber wenn ein
anderer tag ist warum auch immer
und der ist dann aber auch so wie er ist
das auch in ordnung dann werde ich
natürlich ein anderes bild hier
zurücklassen aber auf mich liegt er
heute hier der fokus und das ist immer
eine schwierige situation
und wenn man sich davon nicht frei macht
wird man
versucht man es natürlich auch immer
allen recht zu machen und es ist dann in
dem beruf natürlich eine auflage das ist
etwas was das war kompliziert und
schwierig macht uns gelingt mir auch
nicht immer mich davon freizumachen aber
da ich weiß dass ich als grund mensch
sozusagen zuhause und so weiter
gemacht werde
wir sehen ich mich dann darauf eine
andere mir was anderes nach sagen weil
sie meinen sie hätten mit mir komische
erfahrung gemacht oder so ich weiß auch
halt auch was ich möchte im beruf und
grundsätzlich sind er lieber menschen
gefragt oder
die das machen was man ihnen sagt und so
einer bin ich ganz sicher nicht
hier kann man sich fetzen mir kann man
sich streiten und mir sind auch immer ja
wo ich beten ich werde nicht laut oder
sosa oder unfallschwerpunkt aber ich
habe mal standen aber auch diskutieren
ja dem vertriebs- und ich das auch nicht
ich weiß du dich lieber zum 1 doch nein
das kommt immer auf das irgendwann wenn
wenn ich merke dass es einfach nur um
macht geht das finde ich blöd und wenn
es ein austausch ist und nicht sogar
gewinner ich lernen musste wunderbaren
ich mich gerne an aber
im berufsleben finde ich schon manchmal
aber beim drehen und so kommt man leute
also das ist ätzend also das ist
also heutzutage muss ja jeder einfach
nur noch die klappe halten sonst bist du
gar nicht mehr kompatibel oder was ich
schon sehr auch nicht jetzt nur er werde
alles hier und da gehen muss weil er
seinen standpunkt hat den er vertritt
also mir sind auch grundsätzlich immer
menschen lieber die nicht immer nur
freundlich sind und die auch
unterschiedlich sind
weil sie was andere finde ich und
brechen war erlebe ich eher mein blaues
wunder wenn menschen immer so
geschmeidig daherkommen und
massenkompatibel und dann
bringt das manchmal echt enttäuschung
mit sich also ich finde immer so gerade
raus aber das vertragen viele auch gar
nicht mehr ich mag das aber sehr gerne
gut und ich kann das auch aushalten
deswegen bist du nicht nur beliebt ich
bin glaube ich nicht
so können sie auch etwas seriöses so
hoch seriös weil ich mache da mal eben
darüber gesprochen die ernsthaftigkeit
in dem zugrunde liegt dass du überhaupt
das produzieren kannst was am ende zu
einem zu lachen oder zu schmunzeln
fühlen kann soll ich mache ja eigentlich
immer dinge die auch sozialkritisch sind
das heißt die figuren und gibt dem die
ich mir aussuche und haben natürlich
immer ein unheimliches gewicht große
tragik und
also gut der begriff seriös ist für mich
sowieso ja auch wieder eine frage was
ist denn seriöse und so aber das ist
extremst
wissenschaftlich von daher gut bin schon
dabei
so sagt sein stopp nicht
so
was sind ihre stärken
das ist immer so was ich selber
meine stärken sind
dass ich wenn ich menschen liebe freunde
liebe das ich ist auch zeige
das ist eine starke
und ich schenke gerne also nicht nummer
also jetzt nicht wie materielles
schenken es teilen und das ist nicht
stärken
wenn man nur grüne hier fast aber ich
hab ja ich hab ja nicht reingeguckt also
über du kannst das schicksal möchte so
wovon handelt ihr nächstes buch mein
nächstes buch
mein großes vor ich schreibe gerade an
dem roman und das hat sehr viele
autobiographische züge aber ich würde
keine biografie schreiben aber
davon handelt es ist muss aber nicht
sein das ist das erste ist was in
erscheinung es kann sein dass ich davor
auch noch kleine andere bücher schreibe
so will es noch mal eine
nummer zwei rote zweimal rot
so haben sie als kind unter ihren unter
ihrem nachnamen gelitten
gar nicht
er war viele thema ja klar schama obwohl
im grundschulalter nicht mehr so weit
waren wir damals nicht aber so später
war das immer anders die belustigungen
ich konnte darüber auch immer sehr
lachen und doch hat spaß gemacht
der immer genervt wenn einer witze war
seine nase gemacht hat und dann
das finde ich auch total affig weil mein
name bin nicht ich
ich habe irgendwie eine ganz komische
selbstwahrnehmung was heißt
sie wird könnte ich ja persönlich nehmen
dann kann man nur uns so dass klar ist
mir gegeben wurde da kann ich ja nichts
dafür und ist an sich einfach lustig ist
einfach eine tatsache
also meiner nase ist etwas anders ja es
ist dies leider auch noch im gesicht ja
dann glaube ich dass würdigung ist schon
zu schaffen machen wir ganz ehrlich aber
meinem namen der war der ist einfach
lustig und mit ok schlimmer finde ich
immer die gleichen fragen gestellt so
kriegen also viel schlimmer aber das ist
ja nicht der fall was ist ihre größte
schwäche ja das ist
meine größte schwäche ist
ist das gleiche wie die stärke nämlich
der position die positiv zustand ist
sich zu teilen sich zu geben die gefühle
zu geben sich mitzuteilen und wenn das
in die negative richtung
rutscht dann ist eine verschlossenheit
da und rückzug und und nicht mitteilen
und und sehr viel
eigenbrötlerisch es fast autistisch ist
er also was er was die dinge so
verkompliziert und und auch für die
umwelt dann nicht schön ist
und das ist eine schwäche
wenn man nicht raus tritt und da ich mal
das hat man das ab und ist ja lernen
lernt opern oder das heißt du bist offen
ohne die schweiz
um ist jetzt mal sehr pointiert aus zu
tun
ja ich habe schon auch so weit ich kann
auch sehr gut mit mir alleine sein und
schweigen und
wenn man es dann gerade nicht passt mit
dem gegenüber dann
ist das vielleicht demgegenüber dann
hier oder da auch
verschlossen oder die hinter projizieren
ja dann interpretieren irgendwas rein
die mag mich nicht oder die
so denn hier gehen sowieso solche sachen
ab so filme und dann wird das irgendwie
kämpfe ich finde ich und das ist dann
nicht welche dass ich das vielleicht
dann in dem moment nicht so gut
vermitteln kann na und dem anderen so
entspann dich ich bin jetzt gerade
irgendwo ganz anders bei mir
fehlt an die fähigkeit dass zu
moderieren
aber darüber kann es eigentlich
der partnerschaft ist es ja auch so dass
einmal die laune wenn man das mal
persönlich nehmen würde aber ich denke
schon dass es bei mir auch extrem
zustände dann sind sowohl das eine das
andere und dann ist das hat das dann
schon gewicht und auch wenn man so
könnte wenn man wollte immer ihren jedem
moment im moment leben und das versuche
ich ja sehr aber dann auch immer sagen
so und jetzt drei tage gehe ich in die
berge wieder selben geht ja nicht immer
so und dann also dass das für die
anderen leicht dazu machen das ist eine
schwäche für schwächen
so wie wird man ein multitalent
man sollte es nicht versuchen denn das
ist man oder man ist es nicht und die
menschen und ich finde dass in anderen
großstadt in der medienbranche ist das
etwas was viele versuchen viele
versuchen einfach das zu sein was sie
nicht sind und
das ist schrecklich es ist schrecklich
ist es einfach nicht schön und da wollen
viele einfach hip sein und muss
und
das was sie für für unglaublich modern
und zu halten und sind es nicht und sind
eigentlich ganz einfach gestrickt und
gleich auch spießig und so und ich sind
immer toll wenn menschen es schaffen
ihr eigenes ihr wirklich ihr eigenes
leben zu leben so wie sie sind und ohne
so nicht so wie die eltern wollten oder
als auch nicht als gegenbewegung machen
sondern irgendwie dahin finden und er
sich dem annähern wie sie sind und bei
mir ist kommt einfach viel zusammen und
ich habe mich auch ganz lange dagegen
gewehrt ich hätte gerne ich deswegen
also sowas wie du was andere als
durchschnitt empfinden
toll
also
so ist es
super vielen dank was ein schönes
schlusswort
so ist es